I don't know give her the book
algorithms to live by yes ok so that my
favorite example of this is they go that
is really military and in the officer
training course and they basically you
know it's early in the training course
and they say to somebody you know pick
who's gonna be the best officer and they
give some criteria as to what that
definition is and they almost always
pick the strongest looking most you know
egotistical kind of type-a personality
is that's that's the one it's gonna lead
us into battle they're gonna be the best
and when the bullets start flying
usually they're the one who you know
runs into the truck and gets on the
radio you know it's really funny I read
a guy who's really into geopolitics and
and one of his quips was actually it was
an interesting piece but he was saying
he would show a picture of soldiers
right and he goes who are the best
soldiers here and of course you go to
the strap guys with the big arms and
everything the guy who looks like you
they are the skinniest wiry as' because
they're fast yep they're smart and they
know that they have the muscle memory
for just everything they got to do yep
so appearances really can be conceiving
or deceiving and you know I think that's
kind of the that's the thing that's
interesting with crypto I think that I
think that once there is kind of an
agreed-upon set of rules mm-hm
that then crypto could do pretty well
mm-hmm I think that and again I don't
know because I am no crypto expert but I
think that you know institutional
participation is vital yep you've
definitely got to get the bigger
financial institutions being willing yep
and once that happens then then things
might they might develop in a way
unexpected or unfor casted but if
they're involved my guess is that that
is an Imperator that you don't like have
right now right a lot of it is being
announced
they're planning on doing but you know
it's kind of like we'll wait until the
cash is in the bank and when you have
that moment I think I think that will be
a real milestone for the cryptocurrency
community because that lending the
legitimacy of some of these big
financial institutions you know that
that could be huge